where do you put like phil ivey and all
those kinds of people um i mean i'm too
i've i've been
to be honest too much out of the scene
for the last few years to really
i mean for life he's clearly got again
he's got that x factor um
he's so incredibly intimidating to play
against i've only played against him a
couple of times but when he like looks
you in the eye and you're trying to run
a bluff on him oh no one's made me sweat
harder than phil ivey just
um my my bluff got through
that was actually one of the most
thrilling moments i've ever had in poker
was it was in a monte carlo and a high
roller i can't remember exactly what the
hand was but um
i you know i three bit and then like
just barreled all the way through
and he just like put his laser eyes into
me and i felt like he was
just scouring my soul
and i was just like hold it together
live hold it together and he was like
you know your hand a little bit weaker
yeah i mean i was bluffing i i presu
which you know there's a chance i was
bluffing with the best hand but i'm
pretty sure my hand was worse um and
uh and he folded
i was truly one of my one of the deep
highlights of my cricket did you show
the cards are you full
what are you gonna you should never show
in like because especially as i felt
like i was one of the worst players at
the table in that tournament so
giving that information unless i had a
really solid plan that i was now like
advertising oh look i'm capable of
bluffing phil ivey but like why i would
it's much more valuable to take
advantage of the impression that they
have of me which is like i'm a scared
girl playing a high roller for the first
time
keep that going you know
you